qué hace que una célula que se encuentra
dentro de nuestra nariz responsable de
oler por ejemplo una porción de pizza se
vea y actúe de manera diferente a una
célula que está en nuestro intestino y
es responsable de absorber los
nutrientes de esa pizza ambas tienen
exactamente el mismo adn por lo que las
diferencias no se pueden atribuir solo a
ese hecho la respuesta radica en la
expresión de ese adn qué genes se
transcriben activamente y cuáles no y
hay varias formas en que se produce la
regulación génica a nivel de la
transcripción por lo que vamos a hablar
de las principales aquí ahora dibujemos
un gen hipotético y asociado con este
gen hay una secuencia río arriba hacia
la región 3 prima de la cadena o hebra
antisentido también llamada cadena molde
y esta secuencia se llama promotor y hay
otra secuencia entre el promotor y el
gen llamado operador el operador es la
secuencia de adn a la que se puede unir
una proteína del factor de transcripción
y el promotor es la secuencia de adn a
la que se une la polimerasa para iniciar
la transcripción ahora primero en
procariotas tenemos
se llama factores de transcripción
basales que son una clase de proteínas
que se unen en sitios específicos del
adn para activar la transcripción los
factores de transcripción basales más la
polimerasa y otro complejo proteico
llamado complejo mediador de proteínas
múltiples constituyen la maquinaria
transcripcional básica que posiciona la
polimerasa justo al comienzo de una
secuencia codificadora de proteínas o un
gen y luego libera la polimerasa para
transcribir el arn mensajero de ese adn
molde ahora hay otro tipo de proteína de
unión al adn llamada activadores y éstos
mejoran la interacción entre el arn
polimerasa y un promotor particular
fomentando la expresión del gen los
activadores pueden hacer esto al
aumentar la atracción de arn polimerasa
a través de la interacción con
subunidades de la arn polimerasa o
indirectamente al provocar un cambio
conformación al del adn un ejemplo de un
activador es la proteína activadora por
cada bolita
y esta proteína activa la transcripción
del operón luck n col y en el caso del o
perón la n coli se produce adenosín mono
fosfato cíclico osea mp durante la
ausencia de glucosa y éste sea mp se une
a la proteína activadora por acá está
bonito o sea p lo que provoca un cambio
conformación al que permite que la
proteína sea p se una a un adn en un
sitio adyacente al promotor y luego este
activador el saab realiza una
interacción directa de proteína a
proteína con la arn polimerasa que
incorpora la arn polimerasa al promotor
ahora los potenciadores son sitios en el
adn a los que se unen por activadores
para formar un bucle de adn de una
manera específica que trae un promotor
específico al complejo de iniciación y
como su nombre lo indica esto mejora la
transcripción de los genes en un grupo
de genes en particular y aunque los
potenciadores suelen ser lo que se
denomina elementos reguladores ncis
donde si significa lo mismo
actuar en el mismo cromosoma un
potenciador no necesariamente tiene que
estar cerca del gen sobre el que actúa y
a veces ni siquiera se encuentra en el
mismo cromosoma los potenciadores no
actúan sobre la región promotora en sí
misma sino que en realidad están unidos
por proteínas activadoras y estas
proteínas activadoras pueden interactuar
con el complejo mediador que mencioné
anteriormente que incorpora arn
polimerasa y los factores de
transcripción basales que luego pueden
conducir a la transcripción de los genes
aquí dibujé un pequeño esquema de cómo
se vería el potenciador tras el cambio
conformación al del adn por lo que el
adn ahora está dando vueltas aquí
todavía tiene la secuencia promotora la
secuencia operadora la secuencia del gen
y la secuencia potenciadora y tener el
adn en el bucle de tal manera que pueda
entonces incorporar arn polimerasa los
factores de transcripción el complejo
mediador de proteínas y luego tenemos el
comienzo de la transcripción de este gen
aquí ahora hablemos de los represores
los represores son proteínas que se unen
al operador
en el progreso de la polimerasa en la
cadena y por lo tanto impiden la
expresión del gen ahora si está presente
un inductor que es una molécula que
inicia la expresión génica puede
interactuar con la proteína represora de
tal manera que se desprenda del operador
esto libera a la arn polimerasa para
transcribir el gen más adelante en la
cadena de adn un ejemplo de una proteína
represora es la proteína represora
asociada con el operador del operón lac
lo que impide la transcripción de genes
utilizados en el metabolismo de la
lactosa a menos que la lactosa que es la
molécula inductora esté presente como
una fuente de energía alternativa los
silenciadores son regiones de adn que
están unidas por proteínas represoras
para silenciar la expresión génica y
este mecanismo es muy similar al de las
secuencias potenciadoras de las que
acabo de hablar de manera similar los
silenciadores pueden ubicarse en varias
bases río arriba o río abajo del
promotor real del gen y cuando una
proteína represora se une a la región
silenciador adele
se impide que la arn polimerasa se una a
la región promotora ahora algunas notas
sobre las diferencias entre procariotas
y eucariotas en lo que respecta a la
regulación transcripcional en las
propias la regulación de la
transcripción es realmente necesaria
para que la célula pueda adaptarse
rápidamente al medio externo en
constante cambio en el que se encuentra
la presencia la cantidad y el tipo de
nutrientes determina qué genes se
expresan y para hacerlo los genes deben
estar regulados de alguna manera de modo
que una combinación de activadores
represores y raramente potenciadores al
menos en el caso de las procariotas
determinación gen se transcribe en
eucariotas la regulación transcripcional
tiende a involucrar una combinación de
interacciones entre varios factores de
transcripción que permite una respuesta
más sofisticada a múltiples condiciones
ambientales y otra diferencia importante
entre eucariotas y procariotas es el
hecho de que las eucariotas tienen una
membrana nuclear que impide la
transcripción y traducción simultánea de
un gen en particular
y esto agrega un control espacial y
temporal adicional de la expresión
génica